-Our next guest
is a talented actor
you know from the movies
"Buddy Games,"
"Win a Date with Tad Hamilton,
and the "Transformers"
franchise.
You can catch him in
the new show "Jupiter's Legacy,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-What is wrong with you?
We don't kill, ever!
-He was gonna detonate, Dad.
He was gonna take you out
and half the state.
-Then you disable his systems.
You --
You send him into space.
There's a million things
you could've done.
You took the easy way out.
-Did that look easy to you?!
-Sheldon.
-Go.
Go wait for me at The Union.
[ Air whooshing ]
-Please welcome to the sho
Josh Duhamel.
How are you, Josh?
-I'm all right, Seth.
I'm all right.
This is a big deal.
I put my suit on and everythin
for you tonight.
-You look really --
Now, I'm sure that's probabl
the best dressed you've ever
been in your own kitchen.
-Well, at least
in the last year.
This is a good excuse for me to,
you know --
I didn't -- I mean,
I didn't go all the way.
-Sure.
Thank you for your honesty
We do appreciate your honesty.
Josh, this is your first tim
on the show,
but we have been co-stars
in a major motion picture.
We were in the 2011 film
"New Year's Eve."
We did not have scenes together,
which I think is probably
one of the reasons the film di
not make its box office numbers.
-No.
-But, did you enjoy --
I've often talked on this show
with other people in that film
how much fun it was
to work with Gary Marshall
-Gary was amazing.
And although we didn't --
we didn't have
any scenes together,
I did feel your vibrations..
-Thank you.
-...on the set
well after you'd gone,
so, in a way,
we did work together.
At least, I was inspired
by what you left behind.
-I'm glad you got those.
I did leave those for you,
and I'm happy to see
they hit their target.
-[ Laughs ]
-You -- I want to ask
before I ask about
"Jupiter's Legacy,"
true story --
is this a true story,
that in 1997, you won
Male Model of the Year,
and runner-up
was Ashton Kutcher?
-T-That's a fact, Seth.
-Wow.
-That is a true story.
It was -- It was 1997,
like you said.
I went to New --
My first time ever in New York
I was not
far out of North Dakota.
I think I'd left
maybe a year earlier.
And found myself
in this competition.
I'd been living in Californi
and flew to New York for it.
It was probably the most
pivotal moment of my life...
-Sure.
-...beating Ashton Kutcher
You know what I mean?
I mean, the whole week
was about, you know,
who's going to win?
I heard that there was,
like, this --
The word on the street
was that it was between me
this kid from Cedar Rapids
and some other kid.
The kid from Cedar Rapids
was Ashton, obviously.
Well, then, we get up on stage
at the end of a week long of
you know, swimsuit runways
and high-fashion catwalking,
and all that kind of stuff
which I'm sure you can fin
on YouTube or anywhere
on the Internet, really.
And so we're sitting up there,
and it's fifth runner-up,
fourth runner-up,
third runner-up.
Second runner-up is the ki
from I can't remember where,
and then first runner-up
was Ashton Kutcher.
So, which meant
I win this thing.
I mean, I might have won,
you know, Miss Universe.
I was so --
They lifted me up,
I had the sash, the crown,
tears were flowing.
It was --
It was beautiful.
-Did you have --
was there one strength of your
as a male model that you fee
like elevated you up?
Was there one part
of the competition you fee
you were dominant in?
-It was definitely my walk
-Yeah.
-I had the --
My walk was fierce.
-In the late '90s,
I mean, the walk
was a whole different thing.
-Geez, I was trying
to forget about this,
but I appreciate you
bringing it back.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- We both have --
Yours is a little older.
We both have sons named Axel
Did you --
Did you get to have good
father-son time
over the course
of this last year?
-I didn't know
you had a son named Axel.
-Yeah, I got an Axel, too.
-Wow! That's cool.
Yeah, we spent a lot of time -
I have a cabin deep in the woods
in Minnesota,
and it was really
just an opportunity to,
you know, do a bunch
of the stuff that I never
would have otherwise
been able to do.
You know,
I got a tractor out there.
I've got boats
and Jet-Skis and stuff.
And we just -- you know,
I mostly did work,
taught him the things that -
I mean, I grew up out
in the middle of the woods
in North Dakota,
and so it was a good way for m
to sort of relive my own youth
through him and show him
the stuff that I grew up doing
And, you know, again,
that was stuff that I don't know
he would have otherwise
been able to do
just living in Los Angeles
so it's been great
having that place out there.
-So, this is interesting to me
because I feel like
a kid that age,
even though they've got a da
who's in show business,
a dad who is currently playing
a superhero,
I bet at the end of the day,
they're more impressed
that you have a tractor.
Is that accurate?
-Yeah.
Yeah, to Julianna's point,
he doesn't really care.
I mean, he loves superheroes
Don't get me wrong.
That is what he talks abou
90% of the time.
But, you know, to me, it's -
I'm just his dad, you know
And I think that it's almost
more distracting for him
to be able to watch it
and be like,
"That's not you.
That's just a suit
with a wig and a fake beard.
What are you --
You're no superhero.
Superheroes are Superman."
-Yeah.
And, by the way, Superman,
the actual Superman doesn'
get a muscle suit like this.
It really makes the job
a lot easier, let's be honest.
-Yeah, I was pretty
proud of that.
Look how Jacked I look there
I wish I could do that
in real life.
-They're really good.
When you see it there,
you realize, "Oh, they
figured out how to do this."
Like, the superhero era
we're living in
in film and television
has figured out
how to do muscle suits.
-Yeah, they certainly have
And it's so depressing
having to take that thing off,
because you realize
what you actually look lik
underneath it.
-Yeah.
'Cause this is like you,
1997, sash on, and then...
[ Laughter ]
One of the cool things
about this,
you do play a superhero over
the course of a hundred years,
which is --
And I should note that this is
a graphic novel
that I've read
and that I really enjoy.
And there's some real dept
in this character.
Are you enjoying it?
-I had a great time.
I really did.
It was one of those jobs -
It's one of those jobs
as an actor you dream abou
because, you know,
there's a whole origin story
that we start with and sort of
cut back and forth from,
you know, current time
back to the '30s.
And so I got to play this gu
sort of on top of the world,
then loses his father
in a really sort of tragic way
And then he goes into
this mental sort of breakdown,
and he goes crazy, really.
And so it's this journey
that he takes
following these visions
that he has,
which ultimately leads him
to get these powers.
But then you see,
90 years later,
what the repercussions
of that are like.
It's like 90 years of, you know,
the responsibility that it takes
to be this guy
is what we really examine.
And that's
what I loved about it.
And how does that affect
the way you raise your kids.
You know, this guy
can fly around the world
and shoot laser beams
out of his eyeballs.
But he can't --
he's powerless when it comes
to connecting with his
20-year-old daughter.
You know, so he literally
goes to therapy
because he doesn't know
who to talk to
because he feels like
he's losing --
you know, he's losing them
And so I love that
they sort of examine
the psychological aspects of it.
-It's a really cool story,
and I'm so glad it's on screen
I want to finish by asking you
you have
a celebrity doppelganger.
He is a friend of the show
He's a handful.
Timothy Oliphant.
[ Laughter ]
And I --
When I look at this photo,
it's like, "Oh, yeah.
Son of a gun."
You guys look alike.
And you have crossed paths
and agreed on this assessmen
by others
that you are spitting images
of one another.
-Yeah, I couldn't wait
to meet him because all
I ever hear was, "You look
just like Timothy Oliphant."
In fact, I went to a --
I went to a charity
ping pong event
that Clayton Kershaw
was putting on here
in Los Angeles a few years ago
And they do it right on
the outfield at Dodger Stadium
it's one of the most fun events.
And so I go, they had, like,
this blue-carpet thing.
And I go, you know,
I'm talking to the reporters
and stuff before we go in.
And the "L.A. Times" was there
and they start talking
to the dude
for like 10 minutes.
And at the end of the interview,
he says, "So how --
what was it playing
so-and-so from 'Justified'?"
I said, "Wait a second.
You think --
Wait. You think
that I'm Timothy Oliphant.
10 minutes we talked and h
thought that I was this dude
So, I go into the thing,
and sure enough,
Timothy does show up later
to this event,
and I finally got to meet him.
And we talked,
and we laughed about all the -
you know, all the --
all the times we each
get sort of, you know, taken
for the other, for each other.
And he goes, "Here, come here,
take a picture with my family.
So, I'm like, "Okay."
He had his wife and I thin
his three kids, maybe four
Can't remember.
And we all take --
He actually takes the photo,
so I'm sitting there
with his wife and his kids
Well, come Christmastime,
I get an envelope
with a Christmas card in i
with me and Timothy Oliphant's
family saying
"Happy holidays, the Oliphants."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I thought that
was pretty brilliant of him.
And, you know, I was looking
around for the photo,
so I could -- I could, you know,
send it to you guys,
but I couldn't find it anywhere.
But he's a good dude.
-He is a good dude.
A handful, but a good dude
Hey, thanks so much
for being here, man.
It was a real pleasure
talking to you.
And congrats on the show.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
-"Jupiter's Legacy"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back.